hi I'd like to show you how to create a
project and enable billing for Google
compute engine and Google App Engine
to start go to the Google Cloud console
at cloud google.com slash console once
you're logged in click the create
project button to create a cloud project
here we'll just accept the default
project name and the project ID and get
correct it's important to note that
currently there are two separate places
where billion information must be
entered in order to fully activate your
project first we need to enable billing
for compute engine from your project
settings page click enable billing
on this screen select your country enter
your contact information and in click
continue on the next screen enter your
billing information to complete the
billing set up separately we need to
enable billing for Google App Engine
select the App Engine link from the
cloud console click settings this takes
you to your projects App Engine admin
console once there click billing status
under the balloon head in now click
enable billing and they've required set
the balloon administrator here you can
specify your maximum daily budget
they're going to accept the default
value and click Submit now once again
enter your billing information and once
complete you will have an active billing
enabled project